pour que tu rappes respire c'est le nom
de la liste conduite par ali rabais pour
les élections municipales de 2020 une
campagne lancée auprès de benoît hamon
et alain degois fondateur de déclic
théâtre tous deux engagés auprès d'al
hira b l'adjoint délégué à la jeunesse
et aux sports se détache du maire guy
malandain
sans renier son bilan au sein de la
majorité municipale beaucoup a été fait
pour transformer les murs de trappes
pour changer les squares les rues de
trappes guy malandain fait un très bon
travail
né au terme de vingt ans de mandat
j'estime qu'il est temps de transmettre
le témoin et qu'il est temps qu'on
s'occupe maintenant des habitants plus
encore que des bâtiments
parce qu'il faut réussir la
transformation de la ville de trappes on
a réussi sa transformation urbaine
il faut réussir sa transformation
humaine j'estime que être candidat à 83
ans n'est pas raisonnable je les dis à
guy malandain
je me sens libre donc de m'engager dans
une campagne pour proposer une dynamique
nouvelle
une énergie nouvelle une mobilisation
des trappistes pour continuer le travail
engagé
la campagne est axée sur quatre
thématiques l'environnement et le
développement durable l'éducation et le
parcours scolaire l'économie locale et
l'engagement citoyen avec un programme
co construit avec les habitants j'ai
constaté que j'étais bien meilleur que
les projets portés par la municipalité
était beaucoup plus efficace il visait
juste quand qu'ils associent étroitement
les habitants pour la construction du
programme lui-même
je ne vais pas me contenter de réfléchir
dans mon coin avec mon équipe j'irai en
porte à porte en pied d'immeuble dans
les réunions d'appartement en réunion
publique
demandez aux trappistes leur avis sur
les propositions que je porte des
discussions entre alliera belluc miserez
représentants du mouvement d'opposition
trappe à gauche sont en cours l'actuel
maire guy malandain a déjà annoncé sa
candidature comme othman nassr ou
associé à mustapha larbaoui les
élections auront lieu le 15 et 22 mars
prochains